hey I have some really interesting video
for you Elizabeth Warren appeared on the
view yesterday the view is this multi
host talk show that's really become a
pretty prominent place for Democratic
candidates really for newsmakers of all
kinds of lected officials celebrities
whatever but the Democratic candidates
have been stopping at the view and
talking about their campaign platforms
and why they believe they should be the
2020 Democratic presidential nominee the
hosts are sort of politically diverse
the notable right wing on the show is
the daughter of the late Republican
Senator John McCain Meghan McCain and
she mixes it up with some of the
left-leaning guests so yesterday
Elizabeth Warren appears Democratic
senator from Massachusetts running for
president and one of her notable
policies one of her most well known
policy proposals as part of her campaign
platform is the wealth tax a tax that
would be a 2% tax on wealth above and
beyond 50 million US dollars and she was
on the view and Joy Behar wanted to hear
about the wealth tax and wanted to say
how will it work will it affect the
middle class and Meghan McCain kept
trying to interrupt and Elizabeth Warren
takes the approach of pretend I can't
hear a word she's saying
and as Meghan McCain is increasingly and
visibly frustrated with being unable to
get a question into Elizabeth Warren
Elizabeth Warren just keeps talking
steamrolling Meghan McCain and Meghan
McCain becomes visibly annoyed with this
it's an interesting strategy so let's
take a look at the video you'll be able
to get most of what is going on from the
audio as well you'll hear Meghan McCain
continually trying to talk so it'll
start with Joy Behar asking Elizabeth
Warren about the wealth tax you will see
and hear Meghan McCain try to interrupt
multiple times and Warren just keeps on
going like a freight train
McCain starts to interrupt about halfway
through it doesn't go well take a look
well let's talk a little bit yeah planet
I think it's time for a wealth tax in
America
this is a tax on the top one-tenth of
one percent fifty million dollars in
above your fortune in other words your
first 50 million is free and clear but
on your 50 million thin first dollar
you've got to pitch in two cents and two
cents on every dollar not the middle
class now I know a lot about 1/10 of 1%
I don't have plans to increase taxes on
the middle class
okay I figured out how to do every plan
I've done out there without increasing
taxes on the middle class but look at
what a two-cent wealth tax would do for
us Universal child care for every baby
in this country eggs 0 to 500 billion
dollars into our public schools make it
a real billion dollars for historically
black colleges and universities we spent
2 trillion dollars on the military I
said I don't want anyone ever to ask
Elizabeth Warren how she's going to pay
for medical
Elizabeth Warren straight up pretending
that Meghan McCain simply doesn't exist
Meghan McCain ends up sort of like the
person in the corner that nobody's
listening to now I don't know if this is
childish but I did find it very
satisfying to watch Elizabeth Warren
just ignore Meghan McCain and you can
agree or disagree with Elizabeth
Warren's plan for a wealth tax but the
handling of it is just delightful here
now at the same time this is a TV show
and I find it compelling the way that it
was handled but I have no problem with
challenging Elizabeth Warren on her
wealth tax there are arguments to be
made that it's politically unlikely to
become a reality you can make the
argument that it won't work whatever
right I mean that's all fine we can
debate that that's great but Elizabeth
Warren should be allowed to at least
explain the plan without interruption
and a lot of right-wingers I was looking
online a lot of right-wingers are just
curious with Elizabeth Warren saying
Warren is in the wrong Warren won't let
Meghan McCain speak Warren is the guest
Joy Behar asked Warren about the policy
and Elizabeth Warren is explaining it
and she can't get through her
explanation without Meghan McCain
interrupting three or four times now I
do think that there's a lesson here when
people try to prevent you from even
explaining your position with bad faith
interruption attempts maybe you just
talk past them and you don't allow them
to interrupt you and Elizabeth Warren
running a clinic on that there's one
point at the very end of this segment
which I want to watch again with you
where Meghan McCain looks so frustrated
she actually looks offset at someone and
looks very awkward check it out one more
time I would not be surprised you know
sometimes on these shows the I know a
lot of people who have worked on network
and television shows like this and often
the relationships between the hosts
behind the scenes get very weird and
there are times where the hosts aren't
even talking to each other except on the
show and all communication between them
off the air is happening between
representatives I'm not saying that
that's what's going on here but when I
saw you're gonna see it here when I saw
Meghan McCain look off to the side I in
a fraction of a second the scenario that
appeared in my mind is she is disgusted
furious with how she is being treated in
terms of how much time she's being given
or whatever on the show and she looked
to whoever is her representative or
whichever producer has taken her aside
and is kind of giving them the see this
is what I'm talking about you've got to
fix this for me sort of look could be a
complete fantasy but in any case take a
look at the megan mccain reaction here
looking offstage we spent two trillion
dollars on the military I said I don't
want anyone ever to ask Elizabeth Warren
how she's going to pay for medical hikes
I feel like the tiniest bit bad for
megan mccain but come on let Elizabeth
Warren explain her plan then you can
cite whatever talking point you want to
cite in opposition and please can some
Republicans some right-wing pundits
please ask trump administration
officials how are you going to pay for
the Iran war please ask them because
when the left tries to do good things
you can disagree with Elizabeth Warren's
wealth tax approach you can disagree
with Bernie Sanders Medicare for all
plan or whatever how are you going to
pay for it we can't afford it is the
it's on repetition from Republicans and
when you want a pointless war to help
Donald Trump get reelected or to
distract from impeachment it maybe Rand
Paul says we can't afford this but come
on someone stand up on the right and say
how are we going to pay for this war and
don't do it by the way in the thinly
veiled xenophobic way where Tucker
Carlson dia we talked about Tucker
Carlson the other night saying this is
totally misguided in Iran and that we
have domestic problems to focus on
Tucker's right except he wants to focus
on all the wrong domestic problems
including ones that aren't actually
problems so I would love to see a
Republican just stand up how to spine
and seriously say hey guys how are we
gonna pay for this how are we gonna pay
for this and does this make any sense
whatsoever if we believe in checks and
balances I've not seen any serious
Republican politician do that so far
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show continued clips and coverage of all
of these stories and more there we'll be
back right after this
I want to tell you about one of our
sponsors magic spoon remember breakfast
cereal when I was growing up breakfast
cereal was a really big part of my
Saturday mornings then I became an adult
and realized I don't want to be eating
all that sugar I don't want to be eating
all that junk and now breakfast has
gotten much more boring magic spoon is a
new cereal company that has discovered
how to recreate your favorite childhood
cereals with zero sugar 12 grams of
protein and just 3 grams of net carbs
per serving they offer four flavors
based on the classics cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry plus the variety
pack which lets you try them all magic
spoon spent more than a year working
with the best food scientists and chefs
to recreate the taste and texture of
that classic sugary cereal but it tastes
so incredible you would never guess that
it was healthy its keto friendly gluten
free grain free soy free low carb and
GMO free you've got to try it to believe
it because it tastes great my favorite
of course cocoa cocoa go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman grab a variety pack
and try it today make sure to use the
promo code Pakman at checkout to get
free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon dot-com slash Pakman promo code
Pakman for shipping